Ich erinnere mich, wie ich durch die Menge
ging, um zur Verteidigungsposition zu gelangen. Ich
erinnere mich, wie wir
ungefähr 40 Jahre zuvor an der gleichen Stelle waren, bis zu dem Datum der
Antikriegsdemonstrationen bis zu den
Antivietnamkriegsdemonstrationen, als es
Tränengas und die Unruhen gab  In LA
versammelten sich die Leute, es war eine große Nacht der Anti-
Verleugnung, dann war diese Nacht eine große
Nacht der Bestätigung und der Umarmung,
und so war es dieses Klima, weil ich da
stand und darauf wartete, dass der Präsident
herauskam, schaute auf den Ring der Schule
und ich fühlte mich  ausgeglichen und dann begannen Tränen
zu fließen und unkontrolliert und ich dachte,
ich würde mich irgendwie verstecken, weil ich nicht
wusste, wie ich mich ausdrücken sollte, es war sowohl
der Moment als auch die Erinnerungen, aber was
mich wirklich härter traf, war der
Moment, in dem die Erinnerungen weil ich  Ich wünsche mir für einen
Moment, dass der König
nur die Früchte seiner
Arbeit hätte sehen können. Wir wurden am 7. Juni
1963 getötet, unser Freund Lou Hamer, und dann
dachte ich an diese sehr unschuldigen Menschen
Die ärmsten Leute,
die Wahlrechtsklagen eingereicht hatten, die an
diesem Sonntag auf der Brücke in
Selma Alabama so alles schlugen, kamen
sehr schnell auf mich zu. Ich war überwältigt,
weil Männer von ihnen entweder tot waren und
Martha ich mir nicht leisten konnte  Kommen Sie, er war
wirklich ihr Sieg